romain jestin merci d'être avec nous
avant d'aller dans le détail des mesures
est de vous faire réagir à ces mesures
annoncées par emmanuel macron
globalement est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que le gouvernement et le
président ont pris conscience de votre
détresse oui on peut dire qu'il ya une
prise de conscience parce que depuis le
début de la crise finalement les
étudiants ce sont les oubliés le
problème c'est que durant le premier
confinement 31% d'entre eux ont présenté
des signes de détresse psychologique et
on a eu un deuxième confinement là vous
parlez dans votre reportage d'un
possible troisième confinement jusqu'où
est ce que ça va aller donc on a une
prise de conscience maintenant on attend
des actes
alors les actes et il y en a eu
peut-être vous allez me dire ou non
première mesure annoncée et accès à deux
repas par jour pour le prix d'un euro le
repas dans l'est resté dans les restos u
afin de leur permettre donc de faire
face aux conséquences cette fois-ci
économiques de la crise ce que c'est une
bonne mesure elle nss elle était
nécessaire évidemment en bout oui
nécessaire c'est une bonne mesure
c'est c'est la seule bonne mesure
d'ailleurs qu'on peut qu'on peut retenir
et ça répond à une détresse
effectivement financière de la part de
certains de certains étudiants des
étudiants qui sont parfois ne
bénéficient pas des bourses
c'est là vraiment l'intérêt de la mesure
c'est d'ouvrir ses repas à l'ensemble
des étudiants après sur les deux autres
mesures qui ont été mises en avant la
première c'est à l'oreille annoncé le
chèque soutien psychologique
et alors là c'est assez marrant c'est
qu'on préfère s'attaquer aux
conséquences plutôt qu'aux causes c'est
à dire est-ce qu'à la fin de l'année
il va falloir mettre un psy par étudiant
si la situation n'évolue pas la vraie
solution pour répondre à la détresse
psychologique c'est de rouvrir les facs
et la deuxième mesure qui va dans ce qui
semble aller dans ce sens puisqu'il nous
dit d'ouvrir les facs avec un présentiel
qui serait d'un jour sur cinq mois je
vais vous le dire c'est techniquement
quasi impossible j'étais élue à paris 1
jusqu'en novembre
j'ai vu comment ça s'est passé la mise
en place on avait eu d'une semaine
alternée ou qu'une semaine sur deux les
étudiants pouvaient aller à la
mettre en place un système où les
étudiants ne pourrait venir 15 jours sur
cinq contrôler sa savoir à quel cours et
ce qui pourrait aller enfin pourquoi
est-ce que certains viendrait-elle jour
et les autres tel jour maintenir en même
temps un distant ciel parce que ceux qui
sont à la fac forcément pendant ce temps
certains sont chez eux
tout ça ça me paraît être techniquement
faisable le seul système c'est de ré
ouvrir complètement les facs ou alors de
retourner au système de semaine alternée
voilà est-ce que clairement pour vous
c'est un effet d'annoncé parce que c'est
vrai quand on a du mal à imaginer
l'efficacité d'une seule journée de
cours oui c'est un c'est un effet
d'annoncé mais le gouvernement et les
spécialistes dans ce domaine mais moi
j'aimerais porter encore plus haut que
que la question de l'université la
parole des étudiants la question en fin
la priorité c'est qu'on revienne à une
vie normale je crois je crois que les
chiffres les jeunes qui sont atteints
qui qui sont décédés du co lead et qui
n'avait pas de comorbidité je crois que
c'est une soixantaine de jeunes sur
cette crise sur cette pandémie et donc
est ce qu'on lave réellement envie de
sacrifier toute une génération sur
plusieurs mois sur bientôt une année
pour sauver quelques quelques quelques
étudiants et enfin quelques jeunes et
encore une fois les personnes à risque
pourrait très bien rester chez elle et
bénéficier dudit essentielle quand et
autres coûts réels se rendre à la fac on
a quand même l'impression que les
mesures prises sont disproportionnées je
lisais un que les étudiants faisait en
ce moment les élèves de terminale en
tout cas leur leurs souhaits pour
parcours suppose ils veulent choisir la
fac les écoles bref ils émettent des
voeux apparemment l'université la
faculté est boudé par les élèves de
terminale de cette année vous estimez
que les facs sont les parents pauvres
aujourd'hui oui elles sont plus ou moins
sacrifiés on ne voit que les cours en
prépa continue dans les écoles la
plupart des cours continuent enfin c'est
vrai que l'image de l'université quand
elle n'est pas bloqué aujourd'hui bon on
interdit
on interdit aux jeunes d'y aller et ça
donne pas envie et pourtant c'est moi
j'y suis c'est quelque chose de
formidable je peux que conseiller si des
gens nous écoutent d'aller d'aller à
l'université
on a des professeurs remarquable et
c'est vraiment triste d'en arriver à une
telle situation
aujourd'hui globalement quelle serait la
première mesure que vous attendriez la
réouverture totale des facultés c'est
bien ça oui
la réouverture totale des facultés il
quand les gestes barrière ne peuvent pas
être ne peuvent pas être possible
matériellement parce qu'il faut pas être
fou on ne peut pas de demander
l'impensable non plus et bien revenir à
ce système de semaine alternée qui je le
rappelle est s'était fait alors pour la
plupart des facultés en septembre
octobre et ceux qui étaient chez eux
parce qu'ils étaient voilà dans leur
semaine chez eux et bien des caméras
avaient installé avaient été installés
dans les amphithéâtres donc c'est tout à
fait possible et une partie pouvait
bénéficier des cours en présentiel et ça
permettait de garder ce qui est
essentiel au delà de la question
économique à laquelle il a répondu
financière avec se sert pas la question
du lien social
cette nécessité de maintenir un lien
social et de ne pas être simplement des
zombies devant devant nos écrans à faire
des heures et des heures de cours voilà
par écran interposé ça n'a absolument
aucun sens
merci beaucoup en tout cas romain jestin
d'avoir témoigné en direct sur rt france